hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
220 for me today you're watching
gamespot news and there's 217 days till
the end of the year what a completely
useless bang first stop today our
friends at Ubisoft decide to send out
these beeping safes to promote watchdogs
it did not go well while we managed to
crack in two hours no problem it's a
different story for Aussie company nine
msn who called the bomb squad on the
promotional item a reporter was sent a
black safe and a blacked-out note asking
them to check their voicemail we're in
the fictional Aiden Pearce says
something cryptic and delivers the safe
opening code that's all very well if you
have a voicemail which this reporter did
not and after entering the wrong code
the safe started beeping needless to say
wildly are necessary precautions ensued
and a copy of watchdogs was pried from
the safe by police following in Call of
Duty's footsteps of the year for
battlefield hardline has leaked and
here's all the things you probably want
to know the video was designed for
internal briefings rather than general
distribution but the internet being what
it is things rarely stay that way the
game is referred to by its code name
Omaha and it's set to be all about
battles between cops and robbers the
multiplayer modes currently detailed
include a heist mode where robbers
attempt to break into a bank vault and
score loop before they GTFO rescue
wheres what teams work to save hostages
hotwire which is about vehicle chasers
and blood money which has each side
fighting over a gigantic pile of money
the single-player campaign developed by
visceral is all about in miami detective
named nick mendoza it'll have an
episodic structure designed to mimic a
TV drama and they're bringing back
levolution if you really just want to
make sure you can blow [ __ ] up let me
know what you think of the info packed
video lastly apparently Wolfenstein the
new order has been pirated more than a
hundred thousand times that's like a lot
this comes from a report hosted by
TorrentFreak who say the number could
have been even higher if the 43 gigabyte
game wasn't so damn big pirate bay users
accorded si 43 gigabytes holy [ __ ]
and I have to uninstall like 10 games to
play this [ __ ] despite all this things
might not be going too badly for
bethesda because Wolfenstein was still
the top-selling title overall on steam
last week and was only bumped to the
number two spot yesterday after the
release of watchdogs let me know whether
you think parroting games is a problem
in that commenting section down below or
if you prefer you can chat to me on my
twitter where i'm at just mcdonald those
are all the things that i wanted to tell
you about today but be sure to join me
again tomorrow for more news and leave
me your thoughts